rust is an increasingly popular
programming language in this course you
will improve your rust skills by
learning how to build an authentication
server in Rust Akil Sharma developed
this course he is an experienced rust
developer and is a great teacher for
beginners so let's get started in
today's video we're building uh a
authentication server so we'll be using
JWT but for the apis we'll be using a
framework called warp it's a web
framework in Rust
the benefit of warp is that it's a small
lightweight framework so it helps you to
get quickly started by building apis
and and there are a lot of use cases so
in the sense
there might be many projects where you
don't want to build a full-blown server
like you don't want to use actex or you
don't want to use rocket because of the
much bigger Frameworks and with a lot of
features they're also heavier slower
slower to build with a lot of Concepts
right so in those cases you might want
to have something like warp which is
very easy to learn very lightweight very
easy to very fast to get started with
fast to build with and fast to run at
runtime it's also very fast so warp has
a lot of benefits uh and a lot of use
cases
uh so uh by the way we've already built
a project with actex right and was it
wasn't a full-blown project like a very
small simple project I just showed you
how to use actex right uh so you might
want to check that out I think that will
be much before in the in the in this
playlist series because in this video
Even though this framework is much
lighter we're actually building a much
bigger project than the one that we
built with tactics right but the
projects are comparable in in the sense
that
even with this project if you're
building we're not going to be using a
database we're actually just using a
hash map and that hash map we would
already
pre-create the users and then when we
log in we'll just be comparing with the
users that are already created in the
hash map okay so we don't have a
database just a hash map with
pre-created users login and we'll do all
of the things with JWT like creating
tokens authentication there's also one
more thing here which is role based
authorization so we'll have different
routes for users and admin and we'll be
checking
if the user is a regular user or he's an
admin and depending on that we'll be
giving him access to the apis okay
so that also is there so that means it's
uh it's it's almost uh like a proper
project for for JWT right you'll have
regular authentication and role-based
authorization that means you could use
this code
in multiple places
all right so what we'll do now is
um I have
two terminals let me just show you my
uh screen I have two terminals open here
for you guys one is the uh place where
I've already built the project now I
just want to tell you that this project
is already built it's on my GitHub right
so I'll put the link of the project on
GitHub on on this YouTube video but in
case I forget to do that you just need
to know that I'm akhil Sharma 90 on
GitHub and all the projects almost all
of the projects that I've built are
already there and this one is definitely
there because I just built it just
uploaded it all right so
here uh the project yeah the name of
that project would be something like
rust warp zero three example something
like that anyway so now what we'll do is
I'll just run it I'll just say cargo run
okay
and it's running it's running on Port
8000 and I will now interact with this
project so uh the first thing that I'll
do is I will hit the login route okay on
a different terminal as you can see I'm
running I'm hitting the uh the login
route
all right and I'm inputting the email
which is user at userland.com and
password1234 because this user is
already created in my hash map which is
there in the session memory of the
project which is running at the moment
right there's no database like I said
just a hash map
when I log in I get the token so this is
what the JWT is doing here it's creating
a token for us now what I'll do is I'll
go ahead and I'll save this token
somewhere okay so I recommend if in case
you also have this project in your
running it long
you might want to save this as well but
anyways this is just a demo so in case
you haven't forged my project from
GitHub and are not running it on your
system it's completely all right I'm
just giving you a demo right I have
copied it somewhere the the token and
now I'm going to try to hit the user
route okay so I'll just press enter
enter a couple of times
hit the user route and it says as you
see Hello user one that means
um
that means
the um jwd is able to determine that
this user already exists and it's able
to check the token it's also unable to
get the information like the user type
from the token so this means it allows
me to hit and it also sends back a
responsing hello user one
okay
uh now what I'll do is I will
um I will try to hit the admin route
with this token
okay so let me bring out my command for
the same
sorry
uh
yeah
okay so this is my command my call
command where I'm trying to hit the
admin route with the same token the
token that's meant for the user and
ideally it should not let me in because
this is the admin route meant for the
admin user not for the regular user so
it'll say okay not valid status 401
unauthorized all right so we have
elaborate error handling in our project
and that's also what we'll be building
today
okay and the next thing you want to uh
do is
hit the
login route but with the admin
credentials so what I'll do is I will
hit the admin route
just a second
yeah hit the admin route so you can see
here sorry the login route but with the
admin credentials so I have the admin
created here with different password
like I said these users are already
created uh whenever we start the project
these users get created in the beginning
and I'll show you how to do that we will
initialize these users right so we're
just comparing that this user which
already exists in session memory right
now is it the same as this user that I'm
sending in as request
and yes it is so it's giving me a token
now so what I'll do is I'll just copy
and and paste this token
in a safe place
and what I'll do is I'll try to hit now
the admin route so we saw earlier that
we were not able to hit the admin route
right because it is saying it's
unauthorized but now if we try to hit
the admin route it says hello admin 2
which is with new token you're able to
hit the admin drop all right that's
awesome
so what I'll do now is I will again
um try to hit the user route
and let's see what happens so try to hit
the user route with this admin token and
let's see what happens okay
so I will come here I'll try to hit the
user out but with the admin token
so it remembers it says hello user two
so that means the admin is able to hit
not only the admin route but also the
user out but the user is only able to
hit the user out not the admin route I
think okay I hope that makes sense it's
quite elaborate like the rules that
we've put in quite elaborate and that's
it's like a full-blown working project
you can just pick up the code use it on
your project right if you have let's say
a submission in your college or you're
building something and you're at your
office in your job you're building
something very quick
the best way to build it all right but
jwd it has what but it has these apis it
has error handling it has rules and
authorization authentication everything
is there
anyhow so now let's get started so I'll
just clear this all up I will stop this
over from running and I will create a
new project so I'll say cargo
new
and I'll give a name like uh rust
what
I'll say JWT and and waiting for YouTube
so I'll
CD into it rust warp JWT and YT
all right and you can see here cargo
tumble SRC
now I have not created videos in uh uh
in quite some time now and the reason
for that is that as many of you might
know that my startup armor dot AI was
selected by techstars which was the next
which is a great accelerator and then
recently got selected by outlier
Ventures which is again an accelerator
Tech accelerator and in the middle we
also got grants from companies or
blockchains like Aptos so it's been
extremely busy very very hectic and
basically essentially what armor AI is
it's it's a it's a platform where you
can build security tools so it could be
for web 2 for web 3 doesn't matter uh
the platform enables you to build
security tools really easily that's what
we're building at at armored uh anyhow
just wanted to update you on and why
I've not been making a lot of videos but
then uh now it's getting things are
getting a little bit lighter I'll have a
little bit more time hopefully and
whenever I have time in between the day
I'll just create a quick video like this
right so that
uh unable to also keep in touch with the
Technologies
anyway so I have it here I am going to
open it up in my guess code okay
so there are two terminals right the
other one
I can actually I can just get rid of
that
okay
so here
in my SRC I have a main.rs which is
awesome
but I need two more files I need my
uh all the logic for my authentication
and all the logic for my headers I need
that as well
okay
so
now another thing is it's it's uh
there's quite a lot happening in this
project so I'm just wondering where to
get started with I think I'll just
remove I'll just remove I guess get get
rid of all of this and I'll start by
just creating a user struct okay let's
just do that so let's just create a user
start okay
uh and by the way I I'm not sure if you
can see my screens they're up in the sky
like up in the air now earlier they used
to be on the on on the table now I've
put them up in the air so I will be just
looking here and there will have like
four screens here
um four different screens so
yeah I just want to tell you that so
like there's nobody else in the room I'm
not looking at the person when I'm
looking here at me I'm just looking at
the screens
all right
so
um like this having the same code window
on two different places like instead of
having like a split view just where to
have it on different screens that's what
I uh was doing right so uh in the main
dot RS you have your user uh struct and
I'm going to have a
uid which is string
and email
which is again
string
okay and then password
which is again string now I hope you all
know what structs are you shouldn't be
doing this video if you don't know the
basics of Rush by the way because I I
get a lot of comments on on YouTube
saying that hey I didn't understand uh
anything that you're teaching it's
obviously because I'm expecting that you
know rust uh before if you want to build
a like full-on project with Frameworks
and last right and a lot of people don't
understand that and they just come and
write on my videos I'm not understanding
anything you're saying and you're just
talking you're not explaining it's
because it's because I'm not supposed to
be explaining what is a struct in a
video that's meant for uh building
projects for the web framework right so
I need to give me that much off
like you have to have that kind of
understanding at least so anyways even
if you don't know what struct is it's
basically uh enables you to create your
own custom data types so user is a data
type here which has a uid which is
string email string password and role
okay
because role could be user or admin as
we just saw in the demo
and
in then I have another struct
for the login
request okay so I'll have two things
which is the request and the response
for login
and sorry I'm not able to look at my
keyboard because of this mic let me just
put it here
all right so for the login request I
have uh the email
so I'll send the email
and I will send the
password email and password so it's a
very straightforward simple
straightforward
login
okay and then I have something called as
the login response like I said you know
when you
um
when you make a request for logging in
that that is what this will look like
the login request will always look like
this it will have always an email and a
password the login response will always
look like this will have a token right
so this is my way of defining the write
request and response instructs right so
that it doesn't deviate the project was
interviewed from this
all right so
now because uh I'm sending the request
as Json as you just saw in the terminal
I was using
um
the terminal and I was sending Json
requests right and I was receiving a
Json response so I need to Desert
serialize and serialize right because
just
it's not able to understand Json one and
so on
and a lot of people coming from
JavaScript background they get very
confused in this step they think oh but
why is that you know why is Russ not
able to understand that when JavaScript
understands that by default because Json
is Javascript transition and JavaScript
already understands that by default but
trust does not go Lang does not and
that's why we need to do this okay
so you're going to say DC realize here
in case you're uh you don't you don't
know how serialization dexterization
works there's a very detailed video that
I've created on uh in in this series
itself this figures itself it's in the
towards the beginning
where I explain
the Third Day package which is uh the
third day it's great sorry which is what
which enables us to do digitalization
and serialization so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to first get that
because uh by default rust doesn't have
it so we need to make use of the survey
package Jesus rise and
serialize okay
and you have that now
for the user
uh we'll have to work with the user
object multiple times right
so when we receive the user object in
the
um
you know so we will create the user
object and it'll be stored in the
session memory as a hash map we'll have
to also compare with the user that we'll
get uh you know the user data that we
get in the request and then we'll have
to search for the users so we'll do a
lot of operations with users where we
need to have multiple copies of the
users so I'll just clone this so I'll
just say
I'll give it the ability to that that
we're able to clone it uh very easily so
I'll just say Drive clone
and now what you want to do is we want
to start working on the main function so
I'll say
sync
FN Main
okay
and to be able to enable
the async function we will be using
Tokyo
so in case you haven't worked with Tokyo
there are multiple videos on the same
playlist this rust playlist
multiple videos about Tokyo make sure
you check them out we've already built
projects using Tokyo and the asynchron
the async functionality brings us with
it
so here we'll say let users
equal to
Arc
new
in it
underscore users now init users is going
to be a function
that will help us create default users
so I'll repeat again and it uses the
function that'll help us create default
users
as the program starts so before we make
any requests two users will already
exist in our hashmap to users one being
the user regular user one being an admin
user That's How we'll compare
the user coming in the request with
these users in the hashmap we'll search
for these we'll compare them and that's
how we'll create the token right that's
the whole logic that's going to be there
so Arc that we've just written here
we'll have to add in the appropriate
so it comes in from standard sync Arc
Arc is something that you use usually
with things that you will be using uh
things that you'll be cloning a lot so
it users is something like I mentioned
we'll be cloning quite a bit
oh by the way I'm not sure if I covered
it with C at the end I made C Capital
here in Clone uh you just need to see
that this color changes right so maybe
because I left for a quick break in in
between uh just to get some water
so maybe I didn't show you this which is
C is supposed to be Capital make sure
you do that in your code as well okay
and we got this Arc now Arc unit users
all right
um
so we have this now
and now we quickly create our routes
using warp now we also need warp here so
I'll just quickly write use Warp
and what comes with reject reply
filter we'll need filter as well
ejection and reply okay
and we need warp now to be able to
create these uh routes in the main
function so we'll first say let login
underscore dollars this is for the login
route is equal to Warp
but
login
okay
so this is how the login starts
and we'll say dot and
warp post request so for that means for
login that's the path right login. and
it will be a a post method
and we'll change some more things here
so we'll say with
underscore users
and users dot clones as you know we're
going to including users quite a bit
that's why we have this here
Dot and Warp
body
Json
okay because the request will be in Json
Dot and underscore then
and login underscore
handlers
so essentially what's happening is if
you hit the login route you need to have
the login Handler that's the main thing
right and everything else is just
helping us with that so we have that
it's going to be a post route it's going
to have users so you'll clone the users
and perform some operations in the user
because as you you know with login
you're going to be uh trying to find
those users in the hashmap as we'll
write more code it'll make more sense
but just need to know that with login
you need to have login Handler login
Handler is a function we'll create in a
while just ignore that right then we'll
just create the user out and the admin
route so user route
is equal to
again what
paths
and user
okay
Dot and
with auth
here you'll have role
user
okay so what we're saying is for the
user out it's obviously when we whenever
we had the user Outlet slash user that's
when we're supposed to come into this
chain and the role of that user should
be users there are two rules one is the
user role the other is the admin role
talking about the user role here
and
then
you have the user Handler okay talk
about it just like we have the login
Handler we have the user Handler here
similarly we'll have the admin route and
the admin Handler so admin route let's
go to Warp
path
admin
okay dot and with
auth
and you have the role
which is
admin
okay
Dot and underscore then
admin underscore and
essentially login routes with Slash
login hits login Handler this is a post
request user out with Slash user hits
the user Handler admin route slash admin
it's the admin Handler
and generally let's just Define the
routes so routes
is going to be login route
okay or
user
route
or admin route
might also recover so it the error if
it's not any of these routes we'll have
the recover error
handle rejection handle ejection is
something we'll work with
uh mostly in our error.rs file
but I'll mention it here error
and handle rejection so what is this
error so this error needs to be
in in the top so we'll say
use
error everything from the
error
mod
okay
and I'll just get also everything from
the auth
so error and auth are these two files
that we will be using as modules so I'll
also get auth and here we'll have with
hot and comma role right so
we've done here uh
reviews with users will not use yeah so
we've used with auth also and the with
auth you also pass role which is the
user and that's the logic that we'll
handle in our auth DOT orders file so
that's why I've also gotten it from auth
which is
get with the auth and also the role okay
because we're passing the role as well
role user or role admin
and here we can say mod hot
and mod
error
all right
now I need a couple of more things
I need to be able to work with hash Maps
like you know because we'll be creating
multiple users as the program begins and
that's the those are the users that
we'll be comparing with when we have to
do logins so we'll need hashmap and then
I'll need another thing called
infallible we've used it before it's
when we don't want to return any error
that's when we use infallible I'll use
that also later on so I'll just include
them for now so I'll say use standard
just a second I'm not able to look at my
keyboard because of this mic installing
this new setup so you have used standard
and you have collections
cash
okay
and then you have use standard
convert
and parallel
okay
so
we've reached here
finally when you have defined all the
routes you can simply start off
the server so it'll say serve all the
routes and run the server
on 137 comma zero comma zero comma one
comma eight thousand
let's say dot await
okay
that's that
now there's this function called with
users
so here you can go ahead and create that
function so we say
function with underscore users
ticks and users
which is a collection of users with a
capital u so what does user of the
capital user mean
use of the capital u is actually the
struct so multiple of those structs
because we'll have multiple users like I
said
will be uh
collection of these structs basically
regulation of these trucks are assigned
to users okay
okay so implement
filter
essentially what you need to do is
always we have that hash map of multiple
users we have not created those yet but
we'll create that in the init user
function
this function will create it very very
soon but when you have that when you
have that hash map of multiple users you
need to be able to extract them right
that's how you will you know
go user by user extract user by user and
then compare the details of that user
with the ones that you'll receive in the
request okay that's why we are
extracting it so let's say is equal to
users
comma
comma errors
is equal to n value
Plus
clone
save work
any
dot map
mode
enables me to extract users
okay so there are three functions that I
need to write here one is the login
Handler the user Handler and the admin
Handler so I'll at least create outlines
of those functions so I'll say Pub
async function login Handler okay the
one that will be called when I have
somebody hits the login path login
Handler
so it'll have users which is a
collection of the users
have body which is the login request
okay so I'll explain this again users as
a collection of the user with capital
uses struct so multiple of users which
are following this data type are the
users that we'll have in users okay
which is again here which had cloned
and in login Handler you also have the
body which is the login request so login
request is something that you created
here
which will have an email and password so
you'll have that also in the body which
is the request body okay
and we'll have to perform some
operations with that so like like I told
you the users
we're going to get the users one by one
and compare it with what you call in the
body the details that's what we'll be
doing here essentially
and there will be something called as
the web I'll just push it down
something called as the web result so
I'll say
result
reply
match
users users being
multiple leaders right from
the field assigned it to this variable
users
and you're going to
how are you going to match you're going
to match them by iterating over the
users
and you will find
so like I I explained before that
we have we'll have multiple users and
we'll go over each of those users that
the function will help us do
by iterating user by user we'll go over
them and then we'll compare them with
the details that we get in the request
That's How we'll come to know if this
user matches this user which is there in
the hashmap that's how you
complete the login request
so here will be find
underscore uid comma user
user dot email
equal to body dot email
user dot password equal to the body Dot
password okay
[Music]
so
uh
for this web result right I will go up
at
results
so I'll say type so it's a type that
we've defined type red result
standard
result
now we'll have to Define this result
also T comma
rejection
now to Define this result also say type
result
t
the standard
salt
result
2 comma error
right
and then you have type which is users
our case it's Arc and it's a hash map
of string comma each user
right
so this users that we were talking about
all this while users like I said it's
going to be collection of multiple user
which is the struct and here we've just
officially defined it as a hash map it's
a art enables us to create
uh you know with the help of cloning you
have a hashmap which is string comma use
it
all right
so here
now that we'll find that particular user
which is which matches the email
uh the body email and user email and
user password body parts which matches
that you need to perform some operation
on it okay so that means
and we found it we'll perform some
operation on it
okay
but before we do that I'll just create
the init users function so that things
are much more clear
it's also sum even if I found it all
right so first I'll just create the init
user functions that things make a lot
more sense so well because once I create
this function everything will become so
much clearer to you that all your doubts
will go away
so I'll create
init underscore users function
and this has a hash
map
string comma sorry
string on our user
and start with map
s map
new
map dot insert
this is the first user so we'll say
if you remember here we just created so
the reason I'm following this particular
order is because I'm taking it through
everything so users there's a string
right
the string is actually we use it for
like one two you know the ID of the user
and then we have the user
and that's what we also had here the ID
of the user and the user because we'll
have multiple and we go through multiple
users when we iterate through them so
anyhow so the first thing is from I'll
create one user number one
comma
and I'll say here
user which is if you see capital u you
mean you you know that I'm talking about
the user the struct
so here I have something called the uid
which is string
from one
okay
why because it starts with uid
right
and then I have something called as
email which is
again string from
user at the rate user to land.com
comma
password
restraint from one two three four these
are all hard-coded values so I'm
creating a hash map with these exact
users and if you remember the demo that
I showed you we were actually using this
user details we were using this email
exact email exact password to be able to
authenticate that user
that's what we're basically comparing
role
string and this particular user is
has a role of users that's that's why
when we logged in this user and we got
the token we were not able to use that
token to log in to the admin route the
fit member
comma
so
and now we'll say map
dot insert for the next user so we want
to create the next user now
and we'll say
string
from 2
ND user okay
comma
user
and it will say uid
string
from
two
come on email
again a string
from
admin
rt.com
password is string from
four three two one
and the role is
string form
add
right so this
user's role is admin this is Rolex user
as we know admin is able to log in to
both user and admin
but the user is not able to log into
admin just user
comma here
and then finally we'll just say
map
all right now we can come back here so
now that I've created the
um
init users functions now now everything
is very clear to you right that we have
these two users
and we're basically doing everything
else that we've done here is to compare
the data that we receive in the in the
request
with the users right so when you found
so we are basically in the login Handler
we are trying to get uh we're trying to
find the user which actually matches
this email and password because that's
what we send in the request
once we've done that we want to perform
some operations so we are going to
create a Program forum so we'll say that
token
is equal to auth
create 0w right so in the auth module
you say auth because we have the auth
multiple here
which
is going to have function called create
0p we'll have a function in the auth.rs
file called create JWT
going to just send it the uid comma and
the role
from
string
user dot role we would extract the user
data
Dot map
underscore error
reject custom error
so we'll say
okay
reply it's Json
so I've I've for the time being I've
disabled rust analyzer and we will
activate it so all of everything will
get
um
formatted correctly but I'm just
I'll just disabled it so that I'm able
to type with these
so all of this happens when that
particular user was found
so we created a token but let's say if
no user was found like that which you
know matches the email ID from that user
that we were going through one by one
and it didn't meet the body email or the
body password what do we do then so
we'll say none and we'll just send an
error with reject and we'll say
custom
wrong credentials
error so when we say custom that means
basically we've defined these errors
somewhere on our own
that's what we mean and all that is
there in the error file we'll Define all
the errors now
before I jump there I'll just go through
the entire code once again just to be
sure everything is fine and then we'll
just hear the two handlers the login and
admin Handler which is very
straightforward but before that just
quickly just quickly go through the code
just to make sure everything is
perfectly fine perfectly all right
[Music]
uh we have the user login request the
login response and login route to use
route
yeah everything looks looks all right
okay for now
and now I will just create the user
Handler and the
admin handbook so let's see
Pub async function user underscore
handlers
ID string
we've already have the web result
okay
head so you remember in the demo that
when the user was logging in
it said user one
user to admin to like that hello user
run well so this is where it's all
happening so we just
saying hello user
and we're embedding the uid dash
foreign Handler
you have the exact same function
so let's say
admin Handler
takes in all of this says hello admin
and with the admins ID
that completes our main dot RS files now
we we have the
error file to complete
okay and then we have our auth files to
work on
all right so now
you know that we've completed the
main.rs file I will now work on the
arts.rs file okay
so the first thing that I can Define is
the enum roll
and I know that role
has
a role can be of type user which is the
struct that I've created or it could be
admin so two two different values right
user
and
then I'll Implement some functions for
role so for example this
function from string
get the role from string
and you get back role role being the E
number right so
from string uh like in the
request you send the token
from the token you will come to know if
the user is
a user or an admin
and that will be a string right and then
we'll you put that your string you want
that to be in the form of the role the
rule which is either user admin so you
can compare
so you get back to role right
and now I'm going to match role
if it's admin
I'm going to say role
admin
or role
user
all right
so
there needs to be one more closing
bracket
this makes sense
so in a JW token
to create a JW token you need claims
also right so we'll I'll create the
claims
struct here
but I'll come back to it
once I create the
creates GW function
okay so here we have the
create jwd function
which helps us create the token
so here first you have the uid which is
a string roll which is
the role which basically sorry this from
string is small s
make sure you make the change as well
okay so for here role is role which is
the Ampersand role
and you get back the result from here
which is
string
so what all what all does a token
comprise of it's the expiration time or
date time date
and the claims and the header right so
first
let's have the expiration
we need the UTC package here obviously
Etc now which is the time which is right
now
and then you'll say dot checked
add
signed
using Chrono
duration this is valid for 60 seconds
it's the expiration time so if you were
to use this after 60 seconds it won't
function
dot expect
valid timestamp
dot time stamp
okay so now the other thing
is
the claims
and here this will be equal to claims
with the capital c which should be this
struct that will create here the claims
will have
sub which will be string
I have the role which will again be
string and the expiration which will
again be
view size
okay
and here you need three things which is
derive
debug
comma this serialized comma serials
we'll be deserializing and serializing
it but to
have digitalizing serialize you need
survey so we'll say
use 30
serialize comma
serialize right
and we also use Chrono so we'll say use
Chrono
get everything from Chrono essentially
okay
so for claims we've defined what claims
looks like
uh here also for the role
we'll say hash
Drive
and clone
like capital c
comma partial
okay
coming to the claims
we have to work with three things sub
which is actually the uid so two
underscore owned
comma we have the role which is role dot
two undersource string
and we have the expiration which is
essentially expiration as unit size
which is the type right
string you size the types
comma
and
finally as I mentioned the token will
have the expiration claims and you'll
have
header so we'll have header is equal to
header new
using
the
hs512 algorithm
and we'll encode the header
the claims
with the encoding key
from and Source secrets
jwd
Secret
dot map
error
sorry
token
version okay
so first let's
um
let me actually use Json web token
that basically gives us the ability to
decode and code
gives us the algorithm that we just used
right
so you we use something called as
encoding and or the encode function
which requires headers and claims which
we have right now it is in claims the
header will have the the algorithm
different type of algorithms can be
selected by us
and then the encoding key which is
directly secret we have to create that
encoding key right now
algorithm comma decoding
key
comma and coding key comma
header command validation
all these things we need
and when I
also use the fmt package
and I'll need warp obviously
and warp I'll have filters
header
headers cloned
and have http
header
at a map column header value comma
authorization
and we'll have reject
filter and ejection
we will use this now but up until now
what we've done is we have created uh
enum for role
I'll I'll just switch
bring this out here
the enum for role
create the implementation for all so
this shouldn't be here this should be
here actually
okay with the with the E number the data
type
and this is the information of function
for role which as as I said helps us to
get role which is admin and if this
string is admin we'll Define role as
admin which is part of the enum whole
enum otherwise it's user then we have
claims which has role and expiry which
are the two more important
fields
the create durability function takes
some uid and role and sends a result
which is a string which in our case will
be the token actually
and first we create expiration with the
help of Chrono Chrono package helps us
create
the expiration time which is 60 seconds
or the token and expecting about a
timestamp
then you have claims which is uid role
and expiration of all three and you have
header header create a starting of
header with the algorithm that was
uh let's just do 500 in our case which
has which you get from the Json web
token
Library
and
then you use the encode function
so what you do essentially not sure if
you use JS Json web token before but
I've uh I've shown that on YouTube I
think with the node.js video also and
with the golang video also the way to
create a GW token and you can also go to
their website and try this same thing
out the way to create a data token is to
use some information that you will hash
right so you'll create a hash from some
information so you can use this
algorithm
and some information like header and
claims and use the encode function which
will use this algorithm to hash
that data that you send it and you get a
key from it
now to Hash it you use
a secret key which is in our case
database Secret
and we can Define it here so on top we
can just go here
before this you can just say
we'll Define it as constants constant
J
interpret is is a type
u8
Secret
we'll also Define the better
so what's this this is basically the
thing that you see uh
in your authorization so you say
authorization right whenever you send a
token in the request you see
authorization and then you also say
better and then the token okay so we'll
see this value called authorization
you'll see this Valrico better
and general token a little bit secret is
just the constant used for and as the
encoding key to encode our header and
claims and get the hash based on this
algorithm
and this error we have not defined it
yet it will be in the error dot RS file
and we'll work on that in a while
okay so there's another function called
with auth so if you go to your main.rs
file
you'll see this function being used
called with auth with underscore auth
and we
are expecting this function to be
created here
okay
so let's do that so we'll say
public function with underscore hot
let's see what it takes in so this it
takes in the role so you pass in the
role as user or role as admin
again this role or user roller admin are
coming from your enum role of user role
for admin okay
now that we're connecting the dots
things will make sense maybe you are
confused here why we're writing it like
this
but it all makes sense when we have uh
because we had we're going in a
particular order we can't do everything
all at once so sometimes things end up
we write we end up writing some things
before they actually exist on the other
file but now as we have with your
um
connecting all the dots everything will
make sense
okay
so this is the function that you want to
work with now function with auth
and here we have role
takes control
and we'll implement
filter
extract
is equal to string
from
error is equal to objection
headers blonde
dot map
move
headers
error map
header value
so essentially it's just a long way of
saying
we're cloning the headers that you get
in the uh
along with the role you get you throw on
the headers and you basically
um
you call the authorize function that's
what essentially you're doing so in the
authorized functions
we will be passing the headers and the
role
okay and the authorized function is the
main place where we'll write all the
logic so what's happening here is
when somebody hits the user out we want
to because they're also sending in the
token right and the login route when
when they hit the login route because of
the login Handler they will be able to
create the
um the token right so the create JWT
function gets called from the auth
package auth module so creatively
function something that we created right
now which basically creates the
token for you so
after you have the token that's when you
call the user route right which starts
with Slash user call that route when you
have a token so here you're passing uh
you're passing the role which is of user
because you're expected to be a user if
you're hitting the user out
so you
check if that user is is legit or not in
the sense he has a right
token or not
if he has a right token only then you
will enter this function called user
Handler
you have the user Handler function
already
it's supposed to send hello user and
then the uid but to be able to reach
here you need
the you need to First
cross this function called with auth
or with auth
as you've seen takes in the role which
is
the the user
and it's going to essentially
call the authorize function
so in the authorized function you're
going to pass the role and the headers
okay
so let's let's actually create that
function here
it's an asym function so async
function authorize
rule comma headers
roll comma header map
so you you might notice that we have to
write a lot of boilerplate code like
here we have to find that role is of
type role and headers of type header map
value here also in in the with auth
function you're doing the same headers
of type header map
error value right all of that we're
defining all of that
but that's only because rust is highly
uh you know has a lot of strict typing
and it ensures that you don't end up
creating a lot of errors
so here you'll say match
JWT underscore from underscore header
class headers here
now this function GW from header we will
have to create this function as well
so just write here function
generally from here right so
when you pass the token the jdb token in
the request it goes in in the header
right so you say minus H and then you
say authorization then you say better
and then the token right
so because it's in the header you need
to be able to get it out you need to be
able to get out the token because that's
how you will compare right match
basically means comparing matching
tokens
only if the tokens match can we
uh you know get the user to log in now
the way to match is
we need to uh decode the token as well
right because we've encoded a token
first we encoded using the encoding key
use the encode function and now we'll
also use in the authorize function we'll
have to use the decode
uh
the decode function
so you'll say
in the decoded this is where you'll
store it so decode
claims
Ampersand JWT comma
percent decoding key
from undersource Secret
Ary and Source liquid
comma
and validation
so you got to give it the algorithm with
the help of which the
encoding was done
and you're going to decode with the same
[Music]
decoded
hs512
so this bracket I've created here is
wrong
should be the round bracket
dot map
the error
and just go here reject
custom
again this error we will create jwd
token error
okay
that means there's some issue with the
token
and then
we'll match the role if role equal to
role
admin so when you have
these four dots
right you you're saying that roll admin
which is role meaning role with capital
r enum and admin this role is the same
as the role that we just got
that was passed from the body to this
function
and roll
from underscore
string
decoded dot claims dot role
is not equal to
role
admin
okay
return error reject
custom error
no permission error
yeah so if it's not an admin
if the person is not admin and he's
trying to access
the admin route
then we will say that you don't have
permission to do this
and that will basically be defined in
the no permission error
okay
and we'll say okay
coded
dot claims
dot sub
here we'll handle the error we'll just
return
better sync
eject
custom
header
so this is your authorized function okay
now coming back to this function which
is the
um
GLD from header function
which helps us get get the token from
the header
so here again we'll be working with
those two things two two Fields or two
uh two components of the token of the
request body one is the authorization so
whenever we pass a token right we say
authorization and then
then we say better and then actually the
token right so we need both of those
things so we'll just check for those
things and then after that what comes is
the token that's what we will return
from this function so we'll see
headers
which is of type header map
header value
return a result
which is string
okay
that header is equal to match
errors dot get
authorization
if the value is matching
then we'll return the value otherwise
we'll just return and
errors
saying error is no auth header found
it's no author
header header
right that will basically show that
there was no auth header if there was a
Authority it'll just return that but
there was none we'll just say no auth
header header
and this error we will Define in the
error module
okay
and
you will
um
get that from header so
so I'll have to import those grades so
let's say use create
error
result
okay
so now I have the error create resulting
with result
in web result are these that we've
defined here
anyhow
so coming back to Glory from header
um
so let's get the auth header which is my
matching
standard string
from UTF 8.
header dot as
underscore bytes
foreign
otherwise again we'll return the same
error which is
no auth header header
header and if there's no odd header that
starts
with
better
then we will return
sorry
then we will
return
error
invalid
auth error
headers
okay okay
let's go header dot trim
start
so you're trimming the part which is the
bearer part and after that is the token
right so you whenever you pass token to
make a request
uh you say authent like I said
authorization and then the uh better and
then the actual token so you want to
remove or trim the part to start matches
with
pairs
all right
so that's it that's that completes the
auth.rs file what we'll do is we'll
quickly go through everything just to
make sure everything is correct
and the file
and
then we'll wrap it up
so we have pair you have 0b Secret
you have the role the implementation for
the role
the uh
yeah there's one more thing that's
spending which is where we'll use this
fmt
package which will be in the
Implement fmt display for role
the right way to display the role
to format it so it's format it properly
which is self
comma f
Prime percent of mute
fmt
formatter now this is completely
optional you don't have to do it you
don't have to do this formatting I'm
just doing it
okay so the formatting part is complete
we have claims we have with auth we have
uh create JWT function
we have uh authorize we have gwg from
header
right so quite a bit now the only thing
that's left
is the error.rs file
to do that
I will quickly create an enum for the
types of errors that will have and we'll
we've already used those errors in the
other two files which is the main file
and the auth file so we shouldn't have
shouldn't have uh shouldn't be a big
challenge for us now
so what we'll say is
say
uh
enum
and errors
so what kind of errors that I've used
I've used the wrong
credential error sorry
the wrong credentials error
I've used the GWT
token error okay
obviously token creation error
this one
I've used the no
so that's the benefit with ID using a
good ide is that we get these
suggestions based on
the errors that we already used
the other is invalid auth header error
and in no permission
let me just also right here
error
wrong credentials
223 token not valid
then you have
awt token creation error
no auth error so no error error
foreign
okay
so what does the error response look
like so what I'll say is struct
and error response
looks like this you have
a message it's a string you have status
which is a
string
and then in the beginning what you'll do
is you'll say use so they
serialize
use standard
convert
valuable
because I'll be using this
and this as well so I'll just
bringing them
right now so that I don't have to come
back here
is what is obviously we'll use walk here
XL
http
status code command rejection
comma reply
awesome
okay now that we have everything
you know the basics build
we'll just Implement warp reject
reject call error
and now most importantly the handle
rejection
function
so this one this function hand rejection
which comes from the error module
as the function that we want to create
now so we'll say Pub
async function handle
rejection
now after writing all of this code
obviously we will have to
so I'll just drink some water obviously
we will have to
turn on the rust analyzer
because I'm sure we have made a lot of
mistakes
well that's completely all right
uh
this is all about working in Broad
Strokes
in the beginning
and then
figuring out
how to fix
the code
because you don't want to break your
thought process
too much
so just write
what's coming to your mind here and then
we'll fix everything we'll get into
details and fix everything right now
this is a very different way of working
but it works really well good message
is equal to if error
dot is
not
found
you will say
status code
not found
not found Dot
2 on your Source string
okay here
it will say else if let
sum
the error dot find
error
and then you'll let's
match the error right so if there's no
error
that that error does not exist so you'll
say not found otherwise you'll just if
there is an error you'll just match it
with
these ones
so the first one is the wrong
credentials error then you'll have
the no permission error then you will
have
the jwd token error and then we'll have
the JWT so this match function enables
you to match the exact
error then take
um
the right action
based on the error
now again uh this entire file which is
error handling is completely optional in
the sense you don't have to it if you're
not building clicks production grade
stuff but if you are building production
grade stuff then it's it can really
helpful right you don't want to build a
project it doesn't have any error
handling
so here if I have wrong grain chills
error what I want to do is I want to say
status code forbidden
comma e Dot
do underscore string
clear and Save
status code
on or
authorized
e Dot
to understand string
status code
okay unauthorized
two underscores let's go screen
and for
this
we'll say
status code
internal
server error
done also now all of this that we are
doing right now is very very basic
simple code there's nothing there's no
business logic here nothing that's
happening that's critical it's just
error handling matching the error right
with the right uh
with the error type and then giving the
right status
for it
so at the end you'll say comma
and
status code
right underscore request
e dot two
underscore string
this is e.2 string and then after that
it's
if
error dot find
Warp
checked
mapper mode
allowed
that is underscore sum
foreign
underscore not underscore
loud
and the actual text that will be
returned which is method
not allowed I will be
two
I'll just call string
so in case you don't want to build this
entire file you can just copy and paste
it as well not a problem like copy and
paste it directly from my GitHub
it's all just error handling and once
you do this in this file or in this
project
you can
we can do it in any other file also you
can just copy and paste this so what's
essentially Happening Here is we're
matching the error with the type of
error sending the particular status code
like 401 500 blah blah this is 500 for
example this is 401 for example right
and with the message the error message
right
and here if
there's nothing here then it's just bad
request right
no type of error is matching so it's a
bad request
and then we also uh handling for
method.loud so if if method.log
basically means if it's uh it was meant
for post but you were trying to get
right so that's method not allowed so
that also we're handling out here
here we'll say e print this is just very
basic error handling I'm sure you
already know all of this
and then
comma error
here
that is code
internal server error
on an internal
server
.2 underscore string
then we have let Json equal to
what
reply
Json
error response
status
code Dot
install string
common message
finally
okay
work reply
with
status
Json command code
okay so each
errors has some Json message which is
the Json
and the code which is the status right
the code has code is like 401 500 like
that and the message is basically a Json
Json has both of those things and cool
all right so this is our error handling
file and now we'll go ahead and
um
I'm looking for rust analyzer actually
just say just
come up
yeah so I'll just enable it
and and I get lots of errors
which is nice because we will now
fix them
one by one
all right so in the main dot RS file if
you
go to the login Handler function
just login request needs to be one word
right because that's how we created the
struct
and sum needs to be capital s
so that
fixes two small
errors hopefully
and now we'll just add some dependencies
because those are the packages that
you're using so once we add some
dependencies hopefully the some of the
issues should go away
so here we have uh the version edition
all of that and dependencies I'll just
add
the ones that I'm using so you can just
copy and paste from my calculator file
in case you want to write it on your own
you can do that as well so we're just
using Json retro control key or warp 30
sorry Json
this error Chrome no debug
sorry for profile Dev file test profile
release
so I've added those now and as you see
now for main.rs lot of the uh almost all
of the issues have gone away so it
doesn't show any issues anymore
all the issues that are pending are in
error.rs but now again now again I can
see I mean or others there are there's
five issues again
all right so
we move that and then let's
find the pending issues
now in the auth.rs file there is in the
pub inum role there is one comma missing
put that there
and here instead of fun which is FN I've
written fun which is
fun so when you when you save that
just left the three errors here and then
just four errors here right so certainly
the errors
have become much less
with the error.rs file there are many
things that are wrong
so here
should not have the comma should have
semicolon here
and on top of that you need derive error
bug
out here and derive
serialized bug
out here
so that should hopefully take care of a
few issues
right so now and take a look
four issues are left in the add or RS
file but auth and Main
these two files are working completely
right so this because there's dependency
between these files when I fix issues
here
both these files are now
like they're perfectly fine they don't
have any issues at all you just have to
find
four more issues now
one really small issue that I found here
is that there's double
colon missing
and now we left with one one small issue
and then the final issue is that two
string the S should have been small and
the other dot artist file now we see all
the issues have gone away
so the natural step now is to
do cargo run
and let's just start just one API and
then we're sure everything else will
work because
because there are no issues and we have
built it
very carefully
let's try at least one API
okay so I will
open up
and let's check out
if everything works as expected
foreign
everything's working perfectly fine now
let's say uh if this score is not
correct maybe because I've not tested
all the other apis maybe if this is not
correct you don't have to worry because
I am going to be uploading the correct
code which was which I showed you in the
demo right even though this code is
correct but like just for your peace of
mind I'm going to upload the code which
is
um the one I showed you in demo right so
it's already uploaded in GitHub feel
free to take a look now you know how
that code works you have a complete idea
about that
so we learned a lot in this video quite
a lot right we understood how to use
word power to create apis how to handle
errors
uh how to use JWT in in Rust for
authorization how to encode the code how
we used uh the claims the expiration
and how we created the token and then
the role you know how we had tools for
admin and user
so a lot of stuff lot of stuff in this
video that we've learned I hope you
learned a lot as well thank you so much
for watching
and do share this with your friends to
share this playlist with your friends
it's all free and it's
um good information right thank you so
much and I'll see you in the next video